hello and welcome to the new review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today we are here for some more
jujutsu kaisen madness this time to
delve into the prequel series which is a
truly fascinating look at what spawned
this world and the original ideas that
akatami had with it although what makes
it much more interesting is that i
believe it's all canon as well
which does definitely raise you know a
few questions
one of which is have you subscribed to
the new world review if not then look
i'm not saying that my special grade
eventual curse is going to activate and
deliver you a swift cursey punishment
but just to be safe let's press the
button anyway as it will result in
regular injections of jujitsuki some
content administered straight into your
youtube v
but to continue on with the prequel i
actually shouldn't call it a prequel
because having looked into things after
reading this it turns out that this was
the og jujutsukai sen published in jump
gigger and it was just intended to be a
four chapter short story that got wildly
popular and spawned the sequel which we
now all know and love at least i'm
assuming we all know and love it i guess
if you're watching this video chances
are you're more on the
the love side of the scale but as a
result after finishing it i've been
tossing up over whether or not i should
have read this first because
chronologically this is how people would
have first experienced jude skysen and a
lot of people went into the series with
this prequel story in mind that's a
question i'll be tackling throughout
this video because the thing
about jiu-jitsu guys and zero is that it
does retread a lot of the same beats as
the sequel series so the general premise
is that we have yuta okotsu and he is
scheduled to be executed for housing a
big bad
curso his execution is delayed he then
gets enrolled in jiu-jitsu high meets a
series of fun first-year friends gets
mentored by a certain gojo and has a
mission to sort out this
cursed business and while there are many
different contextual reasons for this
setup it does mirror yuji's beginnings
quite a bit
which i do like looking at it in
retrospect at this stage after
experiencing yuji's journey whereas it
may have felt a bit repetitive if i'd
started with zero and then went straight
into the actual series with a very
similar setup i mean maybe maybe not
that's just the feeling i get that is
the last huge comparison i'll be making
though because in regards to uta he is a
very different character almost
completely on the other end of the
spectrum being meek
weak and with very little belief in
himself whatsoever at least to start
with and that does make him quite
relatable because whilst the brave and
strong characters are fun to live
through vicariously
if most people found themselves
embroiled in this cursed world they
would probably be
far more uta-like in nature and i did
very much enjoy his story the tragedy of
rika being killed and then being
manifested as an insane curse being due
to a promise and nakatami
is very very clever with how that
information was dished out first
portraying it as if rika's feelings
caused this phenomena when in reality
it was that naughty naughty utah and i
also think this is the first time that
we've properly focused on love as a
source of negative energy rather than
the more straightforward things like oh
you bullied me or you destroyed my
environment or even you killed my mother
and then you killed me
sort of stuff but in terms of love it's
almost the opposite to the coast
equation that we export in gojo's past
with the whole negative times negative
equals positive
whereas love can be twisted in such a
way that it's positive times positive
equals negative
and i'm well aware that that doesn't fit
into mathematical sense because positive
times positive
still going to end up as a positive but
you know what love doesn't care about
maths and neither do i
as soon as i saw that word promise
though it immediately made me think of
binding vows and if this situation was
sort of like a precursor to that idea
two people who have made this agreement
together in life and need to fulfill it
through death and yeah it didn't quite
turn out that way but it did still
retain
that flavor of be careful with promises
in this world because they can be very
very meaningful so what i'm still trying
to come to terms with is the fact that
yoota was immediately classified as a
special grade
dude thing which initially you think is
because of rika but by the end of the
series it becomes apparent that no this
is
just how stupidly insanely powerful yuta
is a name that was mentioned i have it
written down here
is michizane sugawara one of japan's big
three eventual spirits
so i guess that's an explanation and it
is a nice little piece of bold expansion
although in addition to that we also
have some solid numbers thrown our way i
think we may have heard this before but
there are only four known special grader
due to sorcerers which
i guess are gojo ghetto yuki and now
utah but much more
interestingly jujutsukai sin zero also
gives us a solid number of special grade
curse spirits being 16.
and this is one of those question
raising features because i imagine that
this is one of those ideas that would
have been scrapped for the sequel series
considering just how absurdly commonly
we
seem to stumble across special grade
spirits although come to think of it
maybe i'm wrong because they do tend to
be labeled mostly as well like
unregistered special grades so the
continuity probably still works there
but it still seems like an abandoned
idea
as for the guy who said that let's talk
about ghetto because he is by far the
most
jarring thing about the prequel probably
the best reason i would give for not
reading zero first
is because i would not have wanted this
to be my first experience of ghetto in
these four chapters he is
incredibly undercooked as an antagonist
he's missing a lot of his subtlety and
comes off as just an evil bad guy for
the sake of having
an evil bad guy even right down to the
way he's drawn he's given these very
classically maniacally evil expressions
and his dialogue is
also pretty generic which to be fair in
a story consisting of only four chapters
there just isn't enough room to flush
him out what we need is a big threat and
he serves that technical purpose
well enough i suppose but it really did
make me miss the ghetto i know from jiu
jitsu kaisen and i appreciate the work
that akitami has put into enhancing that
character adding elements of
understanding empathy and intrigue
although there is a bit of a problem
here at the end of the prequel which
is why didn't gojo either kill or
capture ghetto he was
done injured beyond belief on the floor
completely at the mercy of gojo and i
suppose if you do look at this story in
isolation you could infer that gojo did
do one of those aforementioned things
and look i'm not going to linger on it
too much because i also need to keep in
mind the ghetto story
is not finished and this may have an
easy explanation in the future akutami
doesn't seem like a kind of author to
let this narrative whole side especially
in a world that he tries to paint with
as much realism as possible which
can be tricky when the premise of said
world has to do with supernatural curse
powers
speaking of gojo though he's another
character who i'm very glad i
experienced first in jutsu kaisen in the
prequel he has a lot of his trademark
quirks you know they're there in theory
it's just that they aren't expressed as
potently as akutami would go on to do
like gojo does still feel aloof and
interesting but not quite captivating
and i think a lot of that comes down
purely to art a lot of the time
gojo and i suppose everyone really is
drawn in a very basic pose in the
prequel and this is going to sound
incredibly incredibly minor but one
thing that is really neglected with gojo
specifically
is his hands like seriously in jiu-jitsu
saying gojo's hands are like half of his
character akutami puts a ton of effort
into gojo's body language especially the
hands and that's why i believe he comes
across with such clarity because you
know
something crazy like 55 of communication
is purely visual and that is very very
important in the manga medium because we
don't have access to the remaining 45
percent of verbal communication
due to the fact that we can't really
hear the tone of the characters i guess
our imagination does kind of fill it in
but that's not something the author can
control as well as body language and
yeah i'm starting to go on a bit of a
tangent here but what i'm trying to say
is that between this prequel and
jiu-jitsu
akutami pretty seriously leveled up as
an artist and most of it has to do with
very minor little details like this
another example would be that curses in
jiu jitsu and zero tend to be far less
detailed and grotesque they very much
actually blend into the world as
presented whereas in the sequel series
these curses are often so like bizarrely
detailed that they pop out at you as
something that should not exist with
everything else around it which is great
because that's the entire idea behind
them being these unnatural aberrations
and all that with the second year
students or i guess first-year students
here they were very nice to see in a
more primary
focus but a lot of it is going over
information that we already know
because it needed to be restated in
jutsu kaisen so we have the same story
unraveling maki a showcase of inumaki
and actually panda he even has the exact
same introduction where he is just
referred to as
panda with no explanation whatsoever
just like fushigura did which
is pretty funny and do enjoy me some
panda and actually this is probably one
of the stronger points for reading zero
first because i think it would probably
be better to feel at these guys
alongside utah and then expand upon them
in jujutsu kaisen rather than going from
that expanded knowledge of the second
year students to this very
basic portrayal in the prequel and
funnily enough there is a nice hint of
toto within panda who adopts the
trademark
ask about which girls you like or in
this case which boobs you like which i
suppose was toned down and then
incorporated into toto i'll also say
that i did still really like maki during
these chapters she was a very very good
counter to utah as she is effectively
powerless but super strong and a
supremely driven existence and that
juxtaposed against yuta's endlessly
powerful but weak and heavily unresolved
existence was just pretty great contrast
and also i'm never going to argue with
maki doing cool marky thing so sure
please do provide now what i do wonder
about this prequel is because it does
hit a lot of the same beats does it kind
of give away the end of jujitsukisen i'm
one of those people who's very much in
the camp that i would prefer yuji to die
in the end having completed his mission
with a whole ton of people around him
like his grandfather stipulated
as opposed to say ridding himself of
sukuno and living happily ever after
in this prequel we have a hint of the
latter with you to figuring out the rick
curse and i guess going on to live as
normal of a life as a jujutsu sorcerer
can from here on out i mean without the
curse his execution probably would have
been cancelled and the more we go into
jiu-jitsu kaisen the more i feel like
that
could end up being you juice path as
well which at this stage i still don't
want because the series started out so
boldly with this whole you're going to
die there's no way out of this nude is
just accepting that so i guess we'll see
another thing i should say is that i was
told to read the prequel very
specifically at this point in the series
which i can only assume means that the
information within it is going to be
important for the very next arc which i
imagine means that utah is going to
appear because other than him not
another whole lot really happened here
that we're not aware of in the series as
it stands after hidden inventory or well
actually i suppose a ghetto's family
could also be important his whole gang
of sorcerific
peeps two of which were the little girls
from his flashback which was a nice
tie-in but utah and those characters
aside i don't think anything
majorly important happens that we didn't
already know so i'm bracing myself for
the return of our former protagonist and
wondering how his sorcery has evolved
without the use of rika although my
biggest question mark actually comes
from the idea that this prequel series
is being made into a jujutsu kaisen
movie which seems like quite a brilliant
move there's just enough material in
here to make a satisfying feature and
given that it is effectively an isolated
story you could feasibly walk into it
without having seen
or read jujutsu kaisen itself i'm
curious to see what changes they will
make though specifically
maybe to characters like ghetto and gojo
because this is one of those situations
where crafting a faithful adaptation to
the source material probably
won't actually do those characters
justice because they've both just
evolved so much since this short series
but as for the ultimate question of when
you should read the prequel
this might just be my bias because this
is the way i did it but i don't think
it's ideal to start with it's a fun
series of chapters to look back on with
a greater context of what jiu-jitsu
kaisen has become i just think that
nakatami does such a superior job of
introducing the world and its characters
in the sequel series so starting at that
high
is what i would prefer the first
experience to be but that pretty much
does it for this blind review of
jujutsukai sin zero and what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more jiu jitsu sorcery then please
do check out my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for very maybe
regular jujutsukai send morbidity
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time